[Applause]
and finally new rule don't spin me
when it comes to my health over the past
year the covet pandemic has prompted the
medical establishment the media
and the government to take a scared
straight approach
to getting the public to comply with
their recommendations
well i'm from a different school give it
to me straight doc
because in the long run that always
works better than you can't handle the
truth um
now i get it doctors tell people lies
because they don't trust you to finish
the antibiotics after your dick starts
feeling better
and media well i think we all know if it
bleeds it leads
the more they can the more they can get
you to stay inside and watch their panic
porn the higher the ratings researchers
at dartmouth built a database recently
monitoring the covered coverage of the
major news outlets across the world and
found that while other countries mixed
the good news in with the bad
the u.s national media reported almost
90 percent bad news
even as things were getting better the
reporting remained negative
and politicians they lie because it's
their nature to
cover their ass they don't get blamed if
things goes badly
and also to keep in practice
but when all of our sources
for medical information have an agenda
to spin us
yeah you wind up with a badly
misinformed population
including on the left liberals often
mock the republican
misinformation bubble which of course is
very real
ask anyone who works at hillary's pizza
parlor
and we do know conservatives have some
loopy ideas about covin
like the third of republicans who
believe it couldn't be spread by someone
showing no symptoms
but what about liberals you know the
high information
by the science people in a recent gallup
survey
democrats did much worse than
republicans in getting the right answer
to the fundamental question
what are the chances that someone who
gets coveted will need to be
hospitalized
the answer is between one and five
percent
41 of democrats thought it was over 50
percent
another 28 put the chances at 20 to 49.
so almost 70 percent of democrats are
wildly off
on this key question and also have a
greatly exaggerated view of the danger
of
covid ii and the mortality rate among
children all of which explains why today
the states with the highest share of
schools
that are still closed are all blue
states
so if the right-wing media bubble has to
own things like
climate change denial shouldn't liberal
media have to answer for
how did your audience wind up believing
such a bunch of crap about
covid
a a new report in the atlantic
says the media won't stop putting
pictures of the beach
on stories about covet even though it's
looking increasingly like the beach
is the best place to avoid it sunlight
is the best disinfected and vitamin d is
the key to a robust immune system
texas lifted its covet restrictions
recently and their infection rates went
down
in part because of people getting
outside should let the sun
and wind do their thing
but
but to many liberals that can't be right
because texas and beach loving florida
have republican governors
but life is complicated i've read
that the governor of florida reads
i i know we like to think of florida as
only middle school
teachers on bath salts having sex with
their students in front of an alligator
but apparently the governor is also a
voracious consumer of the scientific
literature and maybe that's why he
protected his most vulnerable
population the elderly way better than
did the governor of new york
those are just facts i know it's
irresponsible of me to say them
look here's what i'm saying i don't want
politics
mixed in with my medical decisions
and now that everything is politics
that's all we do
if their side says covet is nothing our
side has to say it's everything
trump said it would go away like a
miracle
and we said it was world war z trump
said
we should ingest household disinfectants
and we laughed as we should of course
and then it turned out 19 of america was
literally drenching the fruit
in clorox and now of course we find out
that
all that paranoia about surfaces will
[ __ ] anyway
even though we spent hours and hours
wiping our knobs with lysol
and if you've ever wiped your knob with
lysol
i think you know go home and wash the
mail
if you lie to people even for a very
good cause
you lose their trust i think a lot of
people
thank you i think a lot of people died
because of trump's incompetence and i
think a lot of people died
because talking about obesity had become
a third rail in america
i
i know you've heard me pound this fried
drumstick before
but since i last mentioned it a stunning
statistic was reported 78 percent
of those hospitalized ventilated or dead
from cove would have been overweight
it is the key piece of the puzzle
by far the most pertinent factor but you
dare not speak its name
imagine how many lives could have been
saved if there had been some national
campaign
a la michelle obama's let's move program
with the urgency of the pandemic behind
it
if the
if the media and the doctors had made a
point to keep saying but there's
something you can do
but we'll never know because they never
did because the last thing you want to
do is say something insensitive
we would literally rather die
instead
instead we were told to lock down
unfortunately the killer was already in
the house
and her name is little debbie
you